le cyrano de versailles aux couleurs du
gc c'est une nouveauté depuis début 2010
est le groupe a racheté la salle en
décembre il s'est associé à marie-laure
couderc nièce de l'ancien propriétaire
des lieux un partenariat établi sous la
société les cinémas de l'ouest
ce cinéma pour moi c'est le cinéma de
mes grands parents de mon oncle et même
de mes arrière grands parents
donc c'était important pour moi que ce
que ça reste un patrimoine familial mon
grand père a longtemps dirigé l'ugc a
travaillé longtemps avec le président
actuel et quelque part je j'y retrouve
mes valeurs et également voilà donc
c'était un choix assez naturel pour moi
de choisir ses partenaires la juger
c'est a pour mission d'assurer la
gestion et la rénovation des salles le
cinéma sera rendue plus accessible aux
personnes à mobilité réduite
des travaux ont déjà eu lieu dans
l'accueil pour le moderniser
c'est une restructuration lourde toutes
les salles seront concernés par la par
le projet l'ambition si vous voulez très
clairement c'est de faire du cirano
j'allais dire un cinéma de référence du
centre-ville de versailles
donc c'est ainsi marqué l'histoire ainsi
à carnon ya une forte notoriété
finalement ce sera un cinéma ugc avec
une enseigne d'essayer la carte
illimitée tout vin tout leur savoir
faire au niveau de la programmation le
groupe souhaite donner plus d'importance
à la version originale pour les habitués
ugc se veut rassurant et s'engage à
conserver le caractère généraliste et de
proximité du cirano